what's going on guys this is rob and uh  little do you guys know i've actually  got a secondary project  that's actually bigger than comics  explained called pop culture explain  right comics explain focuses on comics  pop culture explained focuses on  everything else and so uh we're starting  things off by explaining celebrities and  then we'll go into like other stuff  that's more pop culture oriented and  kind of  expand from there we're basically  copying the formula of comics explained  right like i blew up with the channel  because i was doing character  explanations so we're doing  celebrity explanations um and then we're  just kind of expand from there but  this is one of the the celebrity  explanations that i've done  which is on stan lee so if you guys  enjoy it make sure you guys head over  and check out the channel you'll find  the link down in the description  uh and yeah i will catch you all later  [Music]  peace